so
foreign
today we are expecting 500
results that are coming in from 500
he wants 822 graduates
this training is going to be hard but i
know these
ladies they are strong
ladies as we are coming here everyone we
know we are coming here for training
and it's good to work together you
cannot move alone
so try to help each other encourage each
other
teamwork guys teamwork together we are
one
here today we are all equals
the only thing that will set you apart
is if you've got character
and spirit and if you do we'll teach you
how to fight
i've spent my life doing things in real
life that most kids can't do on a
playstation
living every kid's dream jumping out of
helicopters blowing stuff
up my background is counter insurgency
warfare
we go out we look for a fight we want to
finish it
akashinga shifts the strategy on
conservation
of having women come out and do what was
perceived to be a male-only role
we started this program with 16 women i
know every young woman
every young girl out there wants to be a
ranger it's a tough job
it's a dangerous job it's one of the
most dangerous jobs in the world
some of you will die doing this job
we're going to be out there
up against armed men they will be
willing to kill elephants
or anybody that's standing in their way
and the only thing standing in their way
will be you
[Music]
these ladies are like me
their life is tough it's very difficult
to survive they work hard
to having food they work hard to have
even clothes to wear
yes before i joined akashinga my life
was very difficult
even to give food to the babies it was
too
difficult i was crying every day
every day i was telling myself
this is a job that i want i'm
sacrificing my
everything my life for protecting the
world
question our stood out from the
beginning from day one when we did
selection with the first program
she walked differently she looked
differently she became one of our best
rangers very quickly
[Music]
now here she is ready to lead the
selection for what will become 240 more
ranges in the next 12 months
now i'm a leader and i'm going to teach
other ladies
to be like me some of them they are
going to finish
some of them they are going to surrender
[Music]
over the next 72 hours we're going to
expose these women to the
four pillars of misery to be hungry cold
tired and wet
we're going to push them to their
physical and most importantly their
mental limits
we're going to see what they're made of
[Music]
when you come here just tell us about
your life
the challenges that you faced
with
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
i'm going to say yes so you're going to
push me back
then you say no yes
no i say yes no i said yes
no i say yes no can you
approach the project you must be
aggressive
and be confident say no
do you want to know can you fight how
strong are you
[Music]
i met a man who was already married
and his parents didn't like me as a
second wife
but i was now pregnant and i don't have
money
but i do my best selling even a little
thing
to support my family
you must know how to fight how to defend
yourself
i can see some of them they are strong
some of them they can become akashing
arrangers
[Music]
what
[Music]
most of the quarters that mean so they
think we are not
strong they were saying you ladies you
cannot arrest
us they were saying when you become
akashinga i'm going to bend your house
i'm going to rape you i'm going to
destroy your family
i feel it in my heart when i see you
disturbing or approaching or hunting my
animals then i'll show you i'll catch
you
i love my elephants like my children
so i must protect them as i'm protecting
my children
[Music]
without protection in these areas
elephants would continue to be
slaughtered
they would become extinct but as they
kill elephant bush they want the task
the ivory people from the villages
sometimes they give us information if
there is someone
who is pushing the animals
a red is dangerous
for us when you see a gun you tell us
that the gun is used to kill the
elephant
it means you are a killer
8 000 elephants were killed in the 16
years prior to our arrival
hurted by fires shot poisoned snared
those women with the arrest that they've
made have been able to break over those
syndicates and drive a downturn in
elephant poaching across this entire
landscape
the women are now the leaders i'm
expendable they're the ones taking this
program forward
for so long we've been blinded by our
egos from seeing the most
powerful force in nature and that's a
woman's instinct to protect
[Music]
this job is dangerous job so you must
sacrifice your life
to be a single lady
aka singal ladies there must be one
group
one family wait as a team work
as their group help each other support
each other
we become sisters
[Music]
i'll teach you to fight back
[Music]
i'll teach you disappear
i'll teach you to use your power
i can see there are some brave ones
inside this group
i'm so excited to tell them they are now
accepted to be a passion garanger
two things we asked for is character
and spirit and then we can teach you how
to fight so long as you have those
things
and you all have them stronger than i've
ever seen anywhere
so everybody congratulations on becoming
an akashinga
trainee ranger i'm going to read the
akashinga odds
so as i'm reading i want you to repeat
after me
is it clear yes
i fought to use my skills and training
i want to use my music training
to protect these animals to protect
these
animals to protect this lens
in this mission in this region
i'm prepared to give my life i prepare
to give my life
this is my duty this is my duty
i
you are now
today we are hundreds
tomorrow is going to be thousands and
thousands
i'll teach you to be brave
i'll teach you to survive
i'll teach you to be akashinga
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
is
hello
[Music]
you